there's nothing easy in this world you
want to fight again
hell yeah oh for real yeah
damn
that's crazy it is
yeah i definitely gotta see that
my last fight i broke all the wreckage
when i was jammed with my records
and i was a young [ __ ] man that's crazy
you ever gonna fight a young lady
no i probably i want to fight um spoiler
um tyson fury
oh yeah he told me what keep doing while
i was here give me an exhibition that'd
be hard what do you think about deontay
wilder
i think he's pretty good i don't know if
he's gonna be typing through if he is
going to start winging and playing he
has a chance but if he's laying back
turn the box was not gonna work what
about deontay wilder versus you in 1985.
i would beat him
[Laughter]
for sure
i don't think i don't know to me like i
said man i i didn't think it was too
many people that could beat you period i
was not a good trainer you my favorite
boxer thank you thank you so you know i
don't know i was watching the special
muhammad aliyah last night yeah yeah oh
and it was just
i knew it happened but it's still like
yesterday right yeah
yeah i gotta watch that i definitely
gotta check that out man
i watched the fight i watched the old
fight last week um
i want the best fights i ever seen um
marvin hagler hitman
three rounds oh my god that's probably i
watched that it's like man cause it's
like i miss it i feel like boxing kind
of fell off a little bit it did because
the best fighters are not fighting the
best fight
sean porter is fighting somebody who's
he fighting crawford yeah that's gonna
be a great fight yeah i want to see that
i want to see blood crawford versus
errol spence yeah um sean porter he's
the real did they fight anybody yeah
he's only got a full spin and he'll
fight anybody yeah i like sean porter
too than anybody yeah they just got to
put the right fights together man you
know what i'm saying i want to see
crawford well i know he's not going to
knock out if he knocks sean pardon i
think he's a bad cat
[Music]
you